what's up buddy
rich can you hear me loud and clear
very well
man i have an interesting uh story more
of a share versus a question
man i grew up amish
and um
you know it's kind of a different world
i would say you know the men are more uh
you know dominating you know toward the
women the women cook [ __ ] for you you
know you go out you
you know we butcher your own beef or or
you know chickens everything
career on gardens
but anyways i i chose to live that
lifestyle when i was 19 years old that's
about 11 years ago
needless to say i got very plugged into
society's comforting lives it was bad
man
like you say the first girl that touched
my pee pee you know i fell head over
heels for and uh
it and that
in the amish community because you pair
bond for life
well you're right right like there's
like there's social um like there's
social uh barriers that are set by the
community
on relationships that prevent that from
ever changing because of societal norms
in that community right so
there it works
like and like i got a lot of respect for
the amish in the way that they live
their life because
like there's a different level of the
amish obviously you know like some use
electricity some drive some use a horse
and buggy sort of thing most of them
grow their own food they all work within
the community they're very tight tight
knit sort of thing very very cool right
and it's probably the way that we've
operated for you know quite a long time
so you left why did you leave by the way
man for different reasons you know they
they lied to me growing up like they had
me convinced you know having electricity
driving cars or [ __ ] like that you know
it's gonna make me go to hell you know
that was a big struggle yeah but my
biggest share my biggest share for
tonight would be uh
you know the first girl that touched my
pp she she instantly started in on uh
you know we get married and all that
dumb [ __ ] first thing that happens is uh
you know she she starts talking about
how you know amish men are jerks she
obviously knew some background on me
and you know that's how not how real men
act and dude i got fat you know seven
years of marriage it turned into a
freaking oh you got married to the first
girl to touch your pee pee
oh hell yes man
this was this was when you were amish or
or after you left
this is after i left down she wasn't an
amish girl either you know she was the
typical
american girl what american girl that's
right
so
man i tell you it's ridiculous you know
my biggest take on everything you say is
uh
the harder i work you know the less
attractive i find women you know women
that were generally attractive to me it
now it's not like they don't even get my
attention i just go and do my thing i
don't find them attractive anymore
like
the moment that you stop putting women
up on a pedestal and you realize that
they're just women
that's that that's really when you're
truly free as a guy
right it's like
whatever like you're like you're
replaceable if you misbehave it's not a
big deal right like you start to
understand the reality of things like i
i'm i'm i'm curious though like
living
as amish and living
not being amish anymore which one do you
prefer
not being amish but there's all there's
also consequences you pay
for sure you know having all the [ __ ]
you had you know that i have now it's
it's pretty crazy you know
i left home with 50 bucks in my pocket
and i watched people that i thought were
my friends at the time
you know that they would make fun of me
my education you know i went to an adult
education center just to get a you know
basic test to see where i'm at they
graded me in like second or third grade
i still i still have no ged or a uh
college degree
but honestly i probably bring in
three times the amount of money the
average person does my age and people i
know they're looking at me like you know
who
you know where the hell you come from
you know
and it's you know they're plugged in you
know go to college that kind of [ __ ] and
it doesn't serve me it never has yeah
school is just one of those things man
all right thanks no i appreciate it man
absolutely thanks for your work
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you